o psol de 20 e hoje vou ensinar como
fazer um shopping gum papel que dispara
3 elásticos em que os elásticos que
agora estão muito na moda para fazer por
saídas como vocês podem ver que a arma é
bastante simples e como é muito simples
é muito fácil de fazer
então basicamente você vai precisar de
duas folhas prima é dogma foi algo maior
ninguém vai depois de obra em quase pra
linha do maio mesmo porque a distância
entre a linha em cada e extreme nada
ainda foi a região que mais ou menos 10
figuras 55 depois dobre para a linha do
centro finalizando assim uma das partes
e fazer o mesmo por outro lado pra ficar
simétrico
para finalizar esta parte do braamcamp
faça o mesmo para mais no folha de papel
o marcar aqui o centro e vejam como é
que eu vou encaixar ali é parte em casa
no meio daquela parte branca fica em
cima daquela para que o mercado vai
começar tesouro
agora tem que encaixar a parte branca na
parte azul mas o que fica é preciso com
uma pistola mas a gente quer fazer é uma
shot gun então eu vou tirar o primeiro
esta parte é que isso vai facilitar
depois terá os de látex e vou encaixar
de novo quarto brincando na porta do
hotel
em seguida vou transformar a partida é
da empreendedora da pistola
na crônica da choque térmico é bastante
simples é só dobrar para trás para
forçar que usar o gravador mas vocês não
tiverem podem usar cola ou então fita
eu quero que meu choque grande para três
elástico fazer três games passinhos
usando este utilizado porque parece que
eu usava os médicos nas operações
se vocês não tiverem este dado não há
problema podem usar uma tesoura mas
daquelas pequenininhas que vão dar conta
do recado
agora estava fica um pouco frágil vocês
quiseram elásticos ela vai dobrar então
convém darmos um quilo força da obra não
foi o maior tombo e roubam como se fosse
um rio aquela das freiras
mas atenção você tem que deixar ela um
pouco largo ou seja o carro por dentro
pois deixaram o que aprendem e de
palmela espalmar é só encaixar na arma
cortar o chez se vocês quiserem podem
acrescentar mais um pouquinho para ficar
ainda mais a já existente
então e só sossegamos o fim espero que
tenham gostado se vocês quiserem ajudar
o canal é só deixar um live se inscreveu
para acompanhar estas coisas caso vocês
não são joão de meriti é estava legal